I was looking at some numbers with
quarterbacks and the number of starts
you know consecutive starts have you
guys followed this at all you know you'd
look at Brett Favre and you forget about
this how many consecutive starts did
Brett Favre have in his career was it I
got like three it was almost 300
consecutive so I got 297
okay so 297 for Brett Favre Eli Manning
is second at 210 Phillip Rivers is 3rd
at 208 tying him with Peyton Manning
Phillip Rivers has started for the
Chargers since week one of 2006 that was
against Oakland hasn't missed a start
since then if he starts the team's first
three games this year he'll pass both
Manning brothers and have the second
longest streak of consecutive starts by
a quarterback all time but that stats
flawed a little bit because Eli is still
gonna be adding to his total but he's
got a long way to go to get to Brett
Farve yes Paul you know it's interesting
when Phil Rivers were coming out of NC
State the knock on him was he had
injured knees and they had some injury
things at NC State that they were having
that was the only question mark about
him well also his delivery yeah they
wondered about that he'd have to start
every game through game 10 to the 2024
season to break Brett Favre's record and
he would be just shy of his 43rd
birthday at this point Phillip Rivers
Chargers quarterback joining us did you
hear those numbers Phillip I caught the
tail end of a mic I can I can although
that was always one I'd really like for
that record consecutive starts as always
one of my favorites and I I'm not gonna
get there dad I'm day that you would be
playing to your 43rd birthday but that's
297 conceived and if we're protecting
the quarterbacks Phillip I mean that's
almost impossible to have that many
consecutive starts at that position yeah
it's crazy just remarkable you know both
on its back in the day when they didn't
quite protect us like they do now but I
know I've been very blessed and very
thankful been able to be out there for
over 200 a row so
yeah I'm not getting the 297 so what's
that one that one's safe at least from
my standpoint what's the closest you
came to not starting again well you know
it's funny because I they do count but
they don't count you know the post
season so it wouldn't necessarily break
the regular season street but that
playoff game would they see how against
the Patriots just probably probably the
closest a regular season game I just
don't ever think that was ever really
any question in my mind and I hadn't had
one in doubt on all these years there's
been good you know who has the most
sacks of you career-wise I do not we'll
take a guess well my guess would be gone
though miller Hiller's correct he's got
16 sacks against you
and Tombaugh Holly's 2nd and Justin
Houston is third do you ever carry on a
conversation with Vaughn I mean if he's
in the backfield that much I'm guessing
that you know hey how are you on good
hey felt good to see you see you in a
couple plays he doesn't say a whole lot
on the field and and I've learned not to
not to be any extra to get him any more
rounds up he's tough enough to deal with
as years I don't need to make it any
harder on our tackles but I've gotten to
know Vaughn a little bit over the years
there's a couple Pro Bowls and things
but yeah yeah he's uh if there is it
makes sense though right not only is he
unbelievable play all those guys you
mentioned but and we see them twice a
year for the last and so thank you that
but you know where he is when you go to
the line of scrimmage
how many defensive players can you say I
want to know where he is because that
guy is a difference maker oh yeah
there's a few I mean you know to me you
have those guys every week who those
guys are it's you got to make sure he is
definitely one of them in a different
category like the Justin who uses the
Taliban leaves and his prime and a
Khalil Mac when he's in Oakland those
guys that you know hey these guys can
ruin the game they can thinking a
pletely ruin the game as we saw bond in
a Super Bowl
few years ago they can ruin the game and
one sec fumbling the thing gets turned
around and
or not you know yeah you got somebody
running open but it doesn't matter it's
not blocking him so all those things the
only my where of Oliver Oliver guys are
what did last year teach you that will
help you this year with this team well I
think it was something that I've known
but that we haven't done as this current
group in a long time and it's when some
close games you know we had we had our
stretch there where we just lost on the
way and certainly I had my hand in
plenty of them where he found a way to
to lose close games therefore a stretch
of years and last year we we were on the
other side of those we found a way to
win those games and so to experience
that together as a group and then go on
the road and win a playoff game we asked
we had some good experiences last year
that we can we can grow from and we got
a taste of the postseason again you know
our focus there in division and one
division championship since 2009 so you
know we obviously know what Kansas City
is and I think different Oh Claude be
tough to well AFC West bias I think
we've had the best division football so
it's active at Division but that's where
it starts for us is is uh trying to win
the West and and be at home we found out
we were so good on the road last year
but at some point you run out of gas and
we ended up doing that ability yeah how
frustrating is that though when you you
know you're that closer at least you
understand it and at your age you know
you you just you have to look at okay
how many more times am I gonna get how
many more chances am I gonna get does
that you know you try to block that out
no I know I think last year it was a
little more of a disappointing the
finish and I was a little more emotional
post game after that pagers game because
of just what you said you're like Josh
we're right here on the doorstep again
and you know not only you're not
guaranteed to be back here it's a whole
nother year it's a whole not here to get
you there and like you said not mean it
was not many left so I'll never forget
the being AFC champion game is the 2007
season it was a 2008 championship game
and we were all banged up and hurt LT
and gates and myself and Hardwick and
Jamal
I mean how you go on and on with all the
industry had those are institutions but
and we got beat in that playoff game and
I remember Noah saying hey we're gonna
be in a bunch of these games you know
made a bunch of championship games and
we had no one cents and it we probably
should have been a bunch of Genesis
games but we had been in one sense and
so they are fleeting and so it is it I
don't think you belong it out I think he
embraced the fact that hey come on now
I mean here we are we're in it I don't
want to window where we're going to be
cape on half the ability to to go get it
done it's just a matter if we do how do
you what role to your kids play after a
tough loss they you know I don't think
they've made losing's I don't didn't
make me what's the word I hate losing
anymore or makes losing any better but I
think it's just perspective I think it's
the one thing when you come home after
loss on the road especially and you pull
in that driveway and there's bicycles
and sidewalk chalk and scooters and
footballs and basketballs thrown all
over the place there you go you know
what everything's gonna be all right
everything's gonna be all right and they
have got their little tougher critics
they used to be in their little now hey
they're like Josh yeah you should hit
that who would get that one little
football dog now but it's it's awesome
it's awesome having the older ones now
that you're able to experience this and
how they pull for the Chargers and get
excited it's uh it's awesome to be able
to do it with them alongside Tiffany and
the kids both he's Phillip Rivers
Chargers quarterback joining a stamp
Patrick show and I don't know if this is
a motivating factor in any way for you
for Brees for Brady that and
Roethlisberger your children get to a
certain age where they can appreciate
what your dorm doing and normally in
that position or that sport
you're not having kids or if you have
kids they're not going to be around to
see you play when you know they could be
proud of dad with so you want to stay a
little bit longer because now the kids
are into this as well does that factor
in at all I think a little I mean a
but not but at the same time I'm excited
to get to coach them so it's a little
bit of both I mean I'm also going man
shoot you're getting older we gonna get
ready to go and go go go play high
school football here before long so
there's a little bit of both but I am I
do enjoy the greatest thing is come from
is besides touchdowns and fun weekends
and winning games and you know watching
the highlights on a Sunday night oh here
come here comes here comes our game you
know and then being excited and enjoying
those times it's really more the
teaching moments that we've had and I'm
actually living them so with the boys
playing you know flag football and
things that happen and actually see them
how I'm dealing with them and then out
then they're kind of getting to start to
experience it and then even just just
teaching moments after a loss I remember
the last time Terry will loss at home
against Denver where he's kind of gave
it away at the end and we got an hour
and a half 45-minute drive home for me
from LA and after the game and I mean
the first ten minutes nobody said a word
and I go gosh here's a good there's a
good so finally I said hey everything's
all right let's still enjoy the car at
home we're gonna be okay baby blue the
game we blew it let's go we gotta move
on we can't we don't pout around about
it so there's certain things have been
like I've actually they're real
experiences that they're actually older
than us now to see what we're gonna see
how dad handles it he's not only gonna
tell us how to handle it we're actually
going to get to watch it so that's been
big for me because it's also helped me
learn how to deal with some of us
adversity and different things that
happen and know that hey you got leave I
guess they're old enough to see it
there's not only just don't tell them
about it they're gonna see the exact oh
[ __ ] yeah but I can't imagine you as a
football coach like your demeanor if
you're not able to cut you know hold the
football control a game and then you're
on the sideline to who who would be what
NFL coach or any pro coach would be like
you on the sidelines with your your sons
but football I don't know you know I
think I'm gonna be most like my dad was
a my dad right that coaches a lot of
passionate intensity but at the same
time he yeah he had he had a he had a he
kept it in check so I'm hoping I'm gonna
be I can't imagine that I can't imagine
and if as you are I can't imagine it but
keeping inject par to be the challenge
but it's uh it's fine my experience with
my dad playing high school football was
so awesome but I want to have that
hopefully I can you know recreate that
same image managed for my for my son's
too so I can already tell I coach them a
little bit and I know it's like football
I know they're young but they enjoy me
coaching them and we have a the
relationship is good in the sense of
that it's just good so I'm looking I am
looking forward to that how competitive
are you with your place among the
modern-day quarterback so with Brady
breeze and Roethlisberger and then you
got the younger guys there and do you
care about ratings your your ranking I
really don't I mean I sound crazy but I
don't I mean yeah these are Pete against
them yeah because they're there because
they're leading the Saints and because
they're leading the Patriots and
Steelers and I think also on the Chiefs
you know but I don't I don't I think
it's I think it's more
I don't know the word but we do need him
remove yourself a little bit and go
gallantly look at that and see that
you're up there was you know and you
look at a list that's panning it far in
Marino and only breeze it and Brady and
relevance burger and Manning and then
rivers I mean it's just it's more like
gosh that's pretty cool you know I but I
don't think that I'm competing like
Ilene where they going branches this
year and where we stack up and I really
don't I
I'm thankful to be in the mix and and
really more concerned with fun the way
to leave this franchise to win a
championship but do you think you're
better than Brady I think I'm better
than Brady no I don't think you'd say
that I think no oh thank you but you
know because it's weird how we try to
assess greatness at that quarterbacking
position though Phillip because I if you
look at resume then we always look at
playoff wins we look at Super Bowls you
know and then Brady has to be the
greatest of all time but then I keep
hearing Aaron Rodgers greatest
quarterback of all time and I'm going
well wait he's only got one Super Bowl
how do you think quarter
should be judged yeah it's a crazy deal
because in that sense because the
quarterback and head coach everyone's
there tied to the record and let me go
back on the brady question no because a
Brady
a Brady led team versa rivers like team
or over so tell you a little bit ahead
scoreboard so go back and answer that
question no so but I see your point
about the Super Bowl I remember thank
you when when uh when the Patriots beat
the Seahawks when the Seahawks when they
had the interception against the
Seahawks down there all fourth of one
and that gave them what their fifth
championship I say yeah you know
everybody said oh he's not the greatest
of all time and I thought to myself oh I
already thought he was one of right I
mean how do you ever decide that it's
like the old Michael Jordan talked about
that forever too but I always thought he
was already one of the greatest all-time
but because they intercepted the pass
yeah now the games of all-time
where's the Seahawks were ran him in and
the Seahawks were the one Brady just
played the exact same game did not he
did anything different you know but it
is it is funny how that works so I don't
I don't look at that that's why I always
think burritos right there in the mix to
turn all these guys and you can't just
go off that I don't think that you can
not in this sport especially but is bro
tell me what you see with Aaron Rodgers
like what is it that people you know it
feels like that's the consensus he's as
good a quarterback as who's ever played
the game
well to me is you look at his touchdowns
two interceptions it's it's unbelievably
farm above better than a buyer's ever
died from ratio standpoint and shooters
your abilities just throw the football
and be accurate and make some
unbelievable plays that physically
physically and I know he's gonna treat
unbelievable mentally I don't know that
part but you had to think he is but
physically I mean he's he's he does he
can do some things that I want sometimes
we watching the quarterback dream and I
go I I'm not I'm not even throwing that
ball
there's certain things physically yeah
that's awesome
do you have the same time okay Peyton
Manning though to me he couldn't throw
it as far as these guys he couldn't he
was always said it was a great passer
but his anticipation
anticipation his you know ability to get
in and out and get his team the best
glaring all those things there's
different ways to to get it done for
sure do you have a no-look pass in the
playbook yeah I think I flicked a few
around I'll look but some of those some
of those get pretty unbelievable last
year but it even even then it's
unbelievable unbelievable year the years
he had last year it is it is it is
interesting now to see I see it
different than I did 15 years ago from
the sense of when you see guys get hot
and you can see we can make a big deal
about everything you know so some of
those some of those no looks were
awesome but they probably got a little
more pub and maybe 13 minutes no Melvin
Gordon questions when's the last time
that happened yeah yeah I figured you
had a stand pat answer hey when's Melvin
getting in philippi III I guess I didn't
answer exactly right about two weeks ago
in training guys have played a bunch of
dues but I hope I hope really sir we
were a better football team with Melvin
he scored thirty eight touchdowns the
last couple years three years and what
he can do in the running past enforces
as has been seen and known so everybody
in this building feels that way about it
so we hope to get him back soon I hope
he comes in when he does I'm hoping that
he does and when he does but he's fresh
and ready to go as I know he's been
working and and getting ready but until
then we got a we got to roll you know we
got to go and it was what was here and
and and also I couldn't Justin Jackson
it's about the young guys in the mix
they've done a nice job in Melvin's
absence so thankfully we do have those
guys in the building if we have to go
without it but I'm certainly hope that
we don't and that melon can just add to
that group when he gets here and then
we'll have you
even a better group when he gets back
here it's great to talk to you I look
forward to it every single season before
it starts I always appreciate your
honesty and the stories you tell Phillip
so thank you we appreciate your time
thank you
that's M Phillip Rivers Chargers
quarterback that's good interview I mean
he did the lifting there but I I just
want you to you know give me opinions
give me some honesty there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]